and now we present amazing facts about
the whale shark the whale shark is the
largest shark in the ocean growing to a
maximum of 65 feet long and weighing
over 10 tons that's more than three
times the size of the formidable great
white shark it also makes the whale
shark the largest fish living today
unlike great whites however the whale
sharks 3000 teeth are tiny and they do
not repeat do not use them to tear apart
mammals in fact their teeth are of
little use so what does a whale shark
eat to survive for that we need a quick
sidebar you're watching the spawning
ritual of the dog snapper the dog
snappers parade up the water at the top
of the parade loop the females lay their
eggs in the male's release their sperm
which leads to whale shark Chow the
whale shark is what's called a filter
feeder as it swims with its huge 4-foot
wide mouth open prey like these dog
snapper eggs gets trapped in a sieve or
rakers while water is expelled right
back out through the Guild's but dog
snapper eggs aren't the only caviar
these big mouse loved wheat kubera
gather in deep water and form a cyclone
that whirls toward the surface the
female turns white to attract males they
swarm her in a frenzy releasing sperm as
she releases her eggs a single kubera
female can release tens of thousands of
eggs and night for as many as five
nights in a row and since whale sharks
can process over 1,500 gallons of water
each hour that means plenty of kubera
eggs here for the gulping after all this
monster of a shark has no interest in
chopping a big Gainey human as long as
they have their more
delicate tiny prey around these giants
are sure to be satisfying